ein toter sechsjähriger Junge auf einem
Campingplatz in Bösdorf in
schleswig-holsteine sein Mörder der
eigene Vater der 39-Jährige Hamburger
ruft sogar selbst die Polizei als die
Beamten am Tatort eintreffen finden sie
den Jungen nur noch tot auf sein Körper
weist mehrere Stichverletzungen auf der
Tatverdächtige Vater lässt sich
widerstandslos festnehmen doch es gibt
Zweifel an seiner Schuldfähigkeit er
soll psychisch krank gewesen sein und
befindet sich nun in einer
psychiatrischen Klinik
und unser Bildreporter jan dovas ist für
uns vor Ort in Schleswig-Holstein Jan
wie ist der aktuelle Stand
nun nachdem der Tatverdächtige in die
psychiatrische Einrichtung eingewiesen
wurde weil eben ein Richter die
Schuldfähigkeit dieses Mannes erheblich
angezweifelt hat sind natürlich auch
noch hier vor Ort Ermittlungen erfolgt
auf dem
Campingplatz hinter mir sind Spuren
gesichert worden alles ist so
kriminaltechnisch abgearbeitet worden
das eben sein muss der besondere Fall
ist in dem Fall eben dass man nicht weiß
und was es sich für eine psychiatrische
Erkrankung handelt und nun die
Ermittlung zeigen
werden was der Auslöser dieser
wahnsinns-39
was ist über das Opfer bekannt es ist ja
der sechsjährige Sohn des Vaters
genau der Sohn lebte wie auch der Vater
und die getrennt lebende Ex Partnerin
von dem Tatverdächtigen in Hamburg beide
an unterschiedlichen Orten
die Mutter die auch nicht hier anwesend
als es zu dieser Tat gekommen ist
wie dieser Junge wir sozial verwurzelt
war und wo genau erher kam dass das uns
nicht bekannt vielen Dank für diese ganz
aktuellen Informationen aus
Schleswig-Holstein und unserem
Bildreporter Jan doves
[Musik]